[Music]
what the people would eat this on
purpose if you leave this for Santa
Claus you're not getting any presents
this year
[Music]
Christmas time
what does something you think about
Christmas time you think about Santa
Claus and you think about Santa Claus
you think about milk and cookies that we
all leave out for Santa Claus and it's a
wonderful joyous thing and of course my
producers because they hate me we're
always thinking of ways that we can take
wonderful and joyous things and make
them miserable and force me to suffer
for the enjoyment of the audience and so
that's what we're doing today instead of
you know doing a taste test of regular
milk and regular cookies I don't know if
that would be good content but I would
enjoy it anyway instead we have fake
milk and fake cookies okay this is like
the vegan fake stuff we've got different
kinds they call it milk
but it's actually not really milk milk
by definition is a dairy product that is
secreted by mammals so I so milk is a
mammals secretions
it should say that on the damn Carton
and if what you're drinking is not
secreted from a mammal stop saying that
word then it's not milk
cashew milk coconut milk Walnut milk
that's like nut juice okay there's a
difference between nut juice and mammal
secretions I can understand why maybe
they don't call it nut juice as I'm
saying it out loud but still it's what
it really is so we've got that and then
we've got different kinds of vegans
vegan cookies and we'll uh who knows
maybe I'll try one of these and I'll say
you know I'm being being a vegan isn't
so bad
all right we'll start with cashew milk
and keto chocolate chip I don't even
know what keto is I mean I've heard it
but is that a uh so that's a like a
non-dairy thing is that what it is okay
so this is so this is a cookie without
carbs
[Music]
it's not even convincing like nothing
that's another thing and people that
drink this stuff they always say oh it
tastes just like real milk you ever had
real milk this is not it it it tastes
like
yeah it tastes like it takes like a like
if you had a bottle of water and you put
a bunch of cashews in it and you left it
like in your car uh for three days and
then drank the water that's been stewing
around with the cashews that's what it
tastes like all right next that we have
uh and then as for the cookie this is
the keto carb-free cookie this doesn't
even look like a cookie I don't know
what this looks like it's like got a
yellowish almost
tint to it it's spongy
[Music]
oh no it's terrible okay it it it fools
you for a second just for a moment I'm
I'm trying I'm like well this isn't too
bad no no at the end you feel on the
back end I don't know what this is made
of
but it's not food you know at the very
end of it
kind of the aftertaste you can tell that
you're eating something that's not meant
to be consumed by human beings and at
the end of the day it tastes like it
looks it tastes like a sponge it tastes
like if you just grab a sponge maybe put
a little bit of chocolate syrup on it
and uh and take a bite of that and
that's what this tastes like next we
have
plant-based milk and gluten-free
chocolate chip but it's not milk though
because plant is a plant a mammal no
it's not
it does do we know what plant this is
coming from can I at least know that
so just any PL is that what it says on
the carton
there are millions of kind of plants out
there who would ever in what other
context would you just what if someone
was a there's like a salad and it's and
all it says is plants you're at Olive
Garden and you're looking at the the
salad menu and there's the plant salad
do I want to know what kind of plant
this is
foreign
that's like a Pepto-Bismol it's like is
this even milk is this this tastes like
net takes like something uh it's kind of
chalky
like a Pepto
thing going on all right now we have the
gluten-free cookie
[Music]
yeah it's not bad I mean no it's bad
don't get me wrong but if you're talking
about like the store-bought Chips Ahoy
you know which I would never eat that
kind of cookie in the first place but
this is a step below that it's
definitely not good I still and I'm not
just saying it's gonna be funny I have
no idea what gluten is but whatever it
is I love it it's great because any food
I've ever had that excludes it tastes
like garbage so I don't know what gluten
is the magic fairy dust that makes food
not taste like garbage I guess I have a
gluten allergy well if I had a gluten
allergy I would just just deal with it I
would I would deal with the consequences
you know using the internet without
expressvpn it's like leaving your laptop
open and unattended at the coffee shop
table most of the time you're probably
fine but what if you turn around one day
and your laptop is gone every time you
connect to an unencrypted Network in a
cafe a hotel or an airport hackers on
the same network can access your
personal data doesn't take a genius to
hack someone all you need is cheap
Hardware hackers can make up to a
thousand dollars per person selling
personal data on the dark web that's why
I use expressvpx recipe BN creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet so that hackers
can't steal your data it would take a
hacker with a supercomputer over a
billion years to get past expressvpn's
encryption but don't let that scare you
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use
just fire up the app and click one
button plus it works on all devices so
you can stay secure on the go secure
your online data today at expressvpn.com
walshyt and get three extra months free
that's expressvpn.com walshyt
expressvpn.com
Walsh YT all right what's next flax milk
and vegan chocolate chip cookie
I didn't I don't know what flax is
either can someone tell me what flax is
you plant flax seed in the ground what
do you get
so you just get more seeds it just it
just makes seeds erupt out of the ground
[Music]
oh my God that's terrible
that is really really bad there's no way
anyone chooses to drink this what and
what why would you do that to yourself I
just don't drink the milk like you don't
need this in your life why would you
ever need this in your life that's what
I understand if you if you
like milk but you can't drink it because
you're lactose intolerant or something
like that and this is the only option
you're just better just don't have the
milk this is like this this is Barnyard
this has a
tastes like it was made out of hay it's
like a bunch of hay that's on the then
sitting around decomposing on a in a
barn somewhere
that's bad okay
the vegan chocolate chip cookie so that
means it has no butter no eggs like all
of the best parts of the cookie is not
in here
[Music]
where's Zach
it's not nearly as bad as I thought it
was going to be
I'm not saying it's good but I'm a
little bit uh
I'm having all kinds of strange feelings
now
I don't know what's happening to me how
are you the vegan cookies not terrible I
mean I
well
I need to think more about that
because I'm just telling you it's not
terrible it's like a it's a c minus you
know
um all right finally Walnut milk and
flax chocolate chip cookies so don't
even know what the hell flax is but I'm
gonna be consuming it again I'm actually
starting to feel sick I have like
whatever the opposite of lactose
intolerant is I have an intolerance for
things that are supposed to be lacked
lactose and aren't
that just that's just pure walnuts that
just tastes like walnuts that's
liquefied walnuts it's not even you can
see the oh you can't see the camera but
it's like a it's a darker brown
consistency
all right
finally this is our flax chocolate chip
cookie I have a feeling this is going to
be truly terrible
that's not
what the [ __ ]
that's so bad
people would eat this on purpose
I didn't know how to describe that it
definitely tastes like flaxseed and I
don't even know what it is
that's
oh it's even worse on the aftertaste it
lingers with you it doesn't it doesn't
let you it clings on doesn't let you
escape
okay
well good so the lesson here is that uh
if you leave this for Santa Claus
um you're not getting any presents this
year
okay Merry Christmas
[Music]